en este vídeo buscaré enseñarles cómo
convertir fracciones a decimales y si
nos da tiempo también haremos decimales
a fracciones vamos a empezar con los
números poco a poco ok vamos a ir
complicando conforme avanzamos pero
ahorita tengamos algo básico que tal
convertir un medio
a decimales cuánto equivaldrá esto y lo
que nosotros haremos para poder saber
qué número representa esto en decimales
buscaremos hacer la división del
numerador entre el denominador así es
que tendremos 1 entre 2
bastante sencillo ustedes me van a decir
oye pero cómo puedo dividir un 1 entre 2
si el 1 es más pequeño lo que queremos
es colocar un punto decimal y añadir
ceros después del punto y con esto no
estaremos modificando el valor pero sí
estaremos agregando precisión y con ello
nosotros también vamos a tener espacio
para poder hacer la división
cuántas veces cabe 2 en el 10 y nosotros
subiremos este punto decimal exactamente
a la misma altura 0 x 2 0
1 - 0 es igual a 1
y podemos entonces bajar el primer cero
que tenemos después del punto decimal
ahora sí cuántas veces nos cabe 2 en 10
10 entre 2 es igual a 5 porque 5 por 2
es igual a 10 y tenemos 10 menos 10 es
igual a cero y aquí terminamos entonces
con eso podemos saber que un medio o 1
sobre 2 es igual a
0.5 o lo podemos también llamar 5
décimas estamos en el lugar de las
décimas
esto se ve bastante tranquilo vamos a
poner un ejercicio un poquito más
complicado hagamos espacio ahora tenemos
uno sobre tres o un tercio vamos a
convertir este un tercio en decimales y
para eso haremos exactamente lo mismo
volveremos a dividir uno entre tres
y añadiré el punto decimal con ceros
para agregar precisión y que con eso
también podamos hacer nuestra división
subiremos el punto decimal y tenemos que
cuántas veces nos cabe el 3 en el 1 pues
0 0 por 3 0
1 - 0 es igual a 1
y podemos bajar entonces él
pero siguiente tenemos ahora sí cuántas
veces nos cabe 3 en 10 nos cabe 3 veces
3 por 3 es igual a 9
y si restamos a 19 nos queda 1 bajamos
el siguiente 0 y tendremos otra vez 10
entonces este número ya no lo sabemos
cuántas veces nos cabe 3 en 10 3 veces
3 x 3 es igual a 9
y si al 10 le restamos 9 nos queda 1 y
se dan cuenta aquí hay una especie de
patrón en la que siempre tendremos uno y
bajaremos ceros y bajaremos ceros y este
3 se irá hacia el infinito
de hecho este tipo de números se les
llama repetitivos decimales repetitivos
y esto nos indica que tendremos
exactamente el mismo patrón no importa
cuántas veces agreguemos ceros así es
que tenemos dos formas de representar
esto podemos poner 0.33 y una barra
encima que nos indique que este es un
número repetitivo o también 0.3 dado que
el 13 es el número que se repite y la
barra normalmente se utiliza más este
punto 33 bueno yo lo he visto más así es
que si regresamos a nuestro ejercicio
original tenemos que 1 entre 3 o un
tercio es igual a 0.3
es 333 y así nos podemos ir hasta el fin
de los tiempos pero también lo podemos
colocar como
0.33
número repetitivo vamos bien vamos a
hacer un ejemplo más esta vez déjenme
tomar un
un número vamos a tomar una fracción
impropia y suena suena complicado pero
ahorita les explico que es una fracción
impropia tendremos ahora 17 entre 9 y
por esto es una fracción impropia porque
el numerador es más grande que el
denominador estábamos acostumbrados a
tener números más pequeños arriba y más
grandes abajo en este caso cuando el
numerador es más grande que el
denominador tendremos un número mayor a
1 así es que hagamos nuestra división
entre 9 vamos a hacer la línea más larga
porque añadiremos nuestro punto decimal
y los ceros que nos darán mayor
precisión
17 es más grande que el 9 entonces 9
cuántas veces cabe en 17 9 por 19 9 por
2 18 el 18 se pasa sólo quedará una sola
vez 1 por 9
es igual a 9 y 17 menos 9 es igual a 8
colocamos el punto decimal
y bajamos el primer cero
ahora tenemos 80 cuántas veces cabe el 9
en el 89 por 9 es igual a 81 se pasa
sólo nos quedará
por 8 9 por 8 es igual a 72
y 80 le restamos 72 tendremos 8 y
bajaremos el siguiente 0 otra vez
tenemos este mismo patrón ya ven
88 / 9 van a ser igual a 8 que otra vez
será 8 por 9 72
si restamos 80-72 volveremos a tener 8 y
así
una vez más se repite un patrón tenemos
entonces que vamos a representar que 17
entre 9 es igual a 1.8 888 888
o volvemos a tomar la forma que les
había explicado hace un momento un 1.88
repetitivo ya nos va quedando más claro
cómo se maneja esto para que esto sea
mucho más evidente vamos a hacer un
ejercicio más
ahora tenemos entonces pongamos una
cifra un tanto más complicada
entre 93
cómo vamos a hacer esto vamos a hacer
nuestra división y pongamos 17
entre 93
colocamos nuestros ceros que nos darán
precisión creo que me emocioné ya puse
muchos bueno las intenciones que veamos
que con esto justo vamos a tener mayor
precisión y nos preguntamos cuántas
veces caben 93 dentro de 1717 es más
pequeño tendremos un cero y pondremos
nuestro punto decimal 0 x 93 0
17 - 0 es igual a 17 bajamos el primer
cero
ahora sí 170 es más grande que 93
cuántas veces nos cabra 93 dentro de 170
si pensamos en que esto fuera un número
cerrado 90 tal vez 90 por 2 es igual a
180 más 2 veces 3 186 nos pasamos por
mucho sólo nos quedará una sola vez
y multiplicaremos 1 por 93 93
si a 170 el resto 93 tendréis 77
ok bajemos el siguiente cero
770 cuántas veces cabra 93 en 770
calcular 8
8 x 93 son 700 44
hagamos la resta 777 44 son
6 llevamos una se convierte en 5 7 5 2 7
7 026 bajamos el siguiente 0
260 cuántas veces que habrá 93 en 260
calculó que 22 por 3 62 por 9 18
si a 260 le restó 186 tendré 4
70 74 y así nos podemos seguir bajando
el siguiente 0 y en algún momento
llegaremos tal vez a acercarnos al 0 que
nos indique el fin de la de la división
pero este número se volverá enorme para
cuestiones prácticas vamos a utilizar
este 0.132 y colocaremos nuestra
respuesta 17 entre 93 va a ser igual a
cero punto 182
e incluso este número lo pudiéramos
redondear hacia las décimas de las
centésimas a las milésimas si es que
hubiésemos seguido hacia adelante ahora
ya tienen ustedes la estructura de cómo
se realiza la conversión de fracción a
decimales voy a hacer un ejercicio de
conversión de decimales a fracciones y
en este caso tendremos 0.0 35
como leeremos esto ustedes ya conocen
los valores posicional es así es que no
está de más que lo volvamos a poner en
este ejercicio este 0 que está a la
derecha del punto decimal está en el
lugar de los décimos
mientras que este 3 esté en el lugar de
los centésimos y este 5 está en el lugar
de los milésimas
estos son los valores posicionales
correspondientes a este número éste 0.35
lo podemos representar entonces como 35
que está multiplicando un milésimo
o lo que es lo mismo
y le decimos
si ustedes tuvieran por ejemplo
vamos a poner un ejemplo aquí vamos a
poner una lista si tuviéramos este
número 0 puntos 0 30
ustedes me pudieran decir ok tenemos
decimos centésimos milésimos tenemos 30
am y les decimos
o también pudieran decir ok a ver este 0
no nos está agregando valor realmente
tenemos información de que hay una
medida mucho más precisa y por eso se
está considerando pero realmente en este
caso el 0 no nos agrega valor este 3 en
el valor posicional de los centésimos me
dice que tenemos 3 centésimos y yo les
preguntaría estos dos son iguales
pues sí sí lo son por qué porque si
dividiéramos ambos tanto numerador como
denominador entre 10 tendríamos que se
elimina este 0 y se elimina este otro y
nos queda exactamente 3 centésimos
qué es lo mismo que los presentes imos
regresando al ejercicio que tenemos de
este lado pensaríamos entonces en tener
35 milésimas y mi pregunta sería esta ya
es nuestra respuesta final para que
nosotros lleguemos a una respuesta final
siempre hemos de buscar la fracción
simplificada que tenemos en este caso al
tener números terminando en 0 y en 5
puedo saber que son divisibles entre 5
tanto numerador como denominador vamos a
hacer esto y simplificamos nuestra
fracción 35 entre 5 es igual a 7
mil entre cinco es igual a 200
en este caso el 7 es un número primo por
lo que solo se puede dividir entre 1 y
entre 7 y el 200 no se puede dividir
entre 7 así es que dejaremos este número
como nuestra fracción simplificada o
respuesta final si hiciéramos la
división de 7 entre 200
comprobaríamos que llegamos exactamente
al 0.0 35 este ejercicio se los voy a
dejar a ustedes para que practiquen y
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo